IMPRESSIVE INFLUENCE IN OUR SASO
SOCIETY.
THIS IS UKHIY
RE
IT I
CONVERSATION FHE SUFFERING
OF OTHER
FRONTS DIRECTOR
SAYS IT SHKATERINA
ATTEMPHAE TV P LAKE.
THAT VETERAN KNEW SOMETHING
HAT WAS E STATEMENT WHEND OFF AT
SOMEONE INFOG
IS A 15
YOU D THAT PRO-PUTIN ANCR
TERVWID
BEEN FORHEINVASIS RSTAND I THE
WE SHOD BE AWARELUENCE ON OUENCR
DID IT SURPRE R ?
>> W FF ALL, THANK YOU MR VI MEU
BECAUSE YON H THINGS
AND SUCH T
STE BUT THIS IS AN
YOU CAN'T -- YOULO LOT OF GU
COULD SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHO COULSAY IN COUPLE OFS ABOUTS
THAT THERE AREAZ SITTING I
KIEV THAT BLENDS KIEV D OTHER
PEOPLE NOW ON THE FRONT
LINES,THG TO DTHEY
ARE GOING WITH,
TOH  TRYING TOESSED TO RUSSIA AN
DESTROY RUSSIAFES WITH
A NUCLEAR WEAP
WEAPONLE FAKES THAT
NOT EVERYONE IN RUSSIA.TRYING
I SUPPOSE O H  WHO COME BACK HOM
FROMK TOON CHANNEL THEAL
>> YOU TALK ABOUT ABSOLU
AF M THIS EK, THA.P. D A PREGNA
PUTSUT HER PICTURE ANDTTER
EN TWEETS, THESETOE WA ARETENDBA
BABY GIR.S. ICA BY
THE AVP AIIUPO
CLMI THAT OP BEGAN DARK,TTING TD
AN
BIRTH TOAT WASN THAT W OF
ACTRESS.
DO PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT IN IA?
>> BECAUSEY T
RMIOY GET OF PEOPLE, TT DO
TION.AD A HABIT OF
MEDIAOUD JUE
CNE SEARCHING ANPERSONALLY GETT
MESSAGES FM
ASG FO
OR RIOTION AIRW VERY
WELL JUST TT MATION A
PEOPLE ARE DEVASTATED
ED.NNOT UNDERSTAND KN
SOME O JUST DON'T READ GLISH.
THEY DNDERSTWH AND THEY DON'TCH.
SO.
ITY WHEN JUST EVERY
ME I HEAHED OF
FAKES OR I REMEMBER
THAT YEARS AGO WHEN EVERYTHING
TATEIATE
FIANNEL HA
TOLD THE STORY AY THAT W
IN U
THE FEEBLE O WAS NO Y. WAS ORED
KNOW AFTERT BELIEVPE TELEVIO
AND THEY STILL TRUST GUYTELLING